ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND GET STARTED.
WE DO HAVE A.
QUORUM SO IF I CAN HAVE THE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE ROLE.
IRWIN HERE VOEPEL.
YOU CHáVEZ.
DALY HERE FRAZIER. GLORIA.
MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI. QUIRK SILVA HERE
SALAS.
SEVEN ITEM WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON
CONSENT ACR ONE FIFTY ONE AND.
LET'S.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AS AMENDED
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IRWIN.
AYE IRWIN AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL AYE
CHAVEZ.
DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MURATSUCHI. QUIRK SILVA.
QUICKSILVER AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
SEVEN ZERO. AND WE ARE JUST
WAITING FOR OUR AUTHOR AND THERE
HE IS PLEASE STEP RIGHT UP
SECOND.
MISTER FRASIER WILL BE.
PRESENTING AB THIRTY TWO OH
NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR FRAZIER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB THIRTY TWO OH NINE WOULD
PROVIDE A FULL PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION.
FOR THE PERSONAL RESIDENTS OF A
DISABLED VETERAN WHO QUALIFIES
AS. ONE HUNDRED PERCENT DISABLED.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS THERE ARE
CURRENTLY ABOUT FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA VETERANS.
WHO QUALIFY AS ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT DISABLED?
VETERANS TO RETURN HOME WITH A
FULL DISABILITY SACRIFICE THEIR
LIVELIHOOD.
TWO IN.
LIGHT LIVELIHOODS TO IN THE
SERVICE OF PROTECTING OUR
COUNTRY.
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
ESTIMATES ABOUT FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DISABLED VETERANS
QUALIFY FOR THE CURRENT PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION.
WHICH REDUCES THE PROPERTY TAX
LIABILITY FOR QUALIFIED VETERAN
WHO. DUE TO A SERVICE CONNECTED
INJURY OR DISEASE.
HAS BEEN RATED ONE HER PERCENT
DISABLED OR ARE BEING
COMPENSATED AT THE HUNTER
PERCENT RATE DUE TO LACK OF
EMPLOYABILITY.
THE RISING COST OF HOME PRICES
ARE DRIVING VETERANS.
OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS MEASURE WOULD PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT TO THOSE
VETERANS THAT WERE SERIOUSLY
INJURED IN SERVICE TO THE NATION.
AND TO THEIR FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIA MUST RECOGNIZE THAT
THE SACRIFICE OF THOSE WHO SERVE
OUR NATION IN CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES IN SUPPORT FOR
SURVIVING SPOUSES. AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO REMAIN IN CALIFORNIA.
AB THIRTY TWO OH NINE WOULD HELP
ENSURE OUR DISABLED VETERANS
REMAINING CALIFORNIA. AND THAT
THE OPTION OF LIVING IN NEAR
MEDICAL AND BASS FACILITIES AS
WELL CEMETERIES AND PLACES A
FINAL INTERMENT. HIS BALANCE
AGAINST THE COST OF LIVING. IN
CALIFORNIA.
MAINTAINING OUR VETERAN
POPULATION ALSO WILL SUPPORT
LOCAL ECONOMIES BY VIRTUE OF THE
FLOW OF FEDERAL DOLLARS TO
VETERANS THAT IT THAT IS
EXPENDED AND CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL PROPOSED INCREASES
INCREASE TO THE STATE'S EXISTING
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION WILL HELP
OUR VETERANS IN FILMS REMAIN. IN
OUR GOLDEN STATE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN HAVE
SACRIFICED SO SO MUCH FOR OUR
COUNTRY BY SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS CHAIR
WILSON. PASS STATE COMMANDER OF
THE DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
DISABLED AMERICAN. VETERANS.
THANK YOU CHAIR IRWIN VICE CHAIR
VOCAL. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE D. A.
V. DISABLED AMERICAN VETERANS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT OUR VIEWS
ON ASSEMBLY BILLTHIRTY TWO OH
NINE. THE PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION
PRINCIPAL RESIDENCE. DISABLED
VETERANS AND THEIR UNMARRIED
SURVIVING SPOUSE TAX LEVY AS YOU
KNOW DE AB IS A NONPROFIT
VETERANS SERVICE ORGANIZATION
COMPRISED OF ONE POINT THREE
MILLION MORE TIME SERVICE
DISABLED VETERANS NATIONWIDE.
AND HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA DEDICATED TO A SINGLE
PURPOSE
EMPOWERING VETERANS TO LEAD HIGH
QUALITY LIVES IN RESPECT AND
DIGNITY. TO HELP FOR FILLED
THOSE PROMISES.
TO THE MEN AD WOMEN WHO SERVED
DAB ADVOCATES
FOR OUR DISABLED VETERANS THEIR
SPOUSES AND DEPENDENTS.
THIS BILL THE FULL VALUE OF A
TOTALLY DISABLED VETERANS
RESIDENTS FROM EVERYONE PROPERTY
TAX AND EXTEND THE FULL VALUE
TAXES I'M XIN TO THE VETERANS
SURVIVING SPOUSE.
VETERANS WHO RETURN WILL RETURN
HOME TOTALLY DISABLED DUE TO
THEIR ON WILL SERVICE TO THIS
GREAT COUNTRY OFTENTIMES HAVE
SACRIFICED THEIR ABILITY TO
MAINTAIN GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT. IN
SUPPORT OF THEMSELVES OR THEIR
FAMILIES.
OFTENTIMES THESE VETERANS HAVE A
CAPPED INCOME MEANING THEY
CANNOT GO AND ASK FOR OVERTIME
TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR LIMITED
INCOME.
SO AS A RISING HOME PRICES IN
CALIFORNIA TO KENYA TRIES
EXPENDABLE INCOME CONTINUES TO
DWINDLE AWAY.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE THE
MEANS TO MAKE SURE OUR DISABLED
VETERANS AND THEIR UNMARRIED
SURVIVING SPOUSES CAN STAY IN
THEIR HOMES. THE JOB SO
JUSTIFIABLY DESERVED.
TO EMPHASIZE THIS POINT THE
AUTHOR OF AB THIRTY TWO OR NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER IN HIS
STATEMENT CLEARLY STATES THE
MEASURE WOULD PROVIDE A
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT TO THOSE
VETERANS. THAT WERE SERIOUSLY
INJURED IN SERVICE U
NATION AND THEIR FAMILIES
CALIFORNIA MUST RECOGNIZE THE
SACRIFICE OF THOSE WHO SERVED
OUR NATION AND CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT FROM
SURVIVING SPOUSES AND THEIR
FAMILIES REMAIN IN CALIFORNIA.
THE D. A. B. ALSO REVIEWED THE
A. B. THIRTY TILL NINE ANALYSIS
REPORT.
FOR THIS IN THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION HEARING. ON
APRIL TWENTY THIRD TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. WHICH STATED ON PAGE
TWO FISCAL AFFECT THE STATE
BOARD OFEQUALIZATION POV
ESTIMATES AT THIS BILL RESULT IN
A STATEWIDE ANNUAL PROPERTY TAX.
REVENUE LOSS OF NINETY ONE POINT
ONE MILLION GRANTED THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT HIT TO THE STATE.
COUNTIES MUNICIPALITIES TAX
REVENUE COFFERS HOWEVER THE DAB
TAKES EXCEPTION TO DANCE
ANALYSIS BECAUSE OF THE
ALGORITHMS USE AN ANALYSIS DO
NOT ACCOUNT FOR NET AFFECT. THE
TAX SAVINGS REALIZED BY THE
DISABLED VETERAN AND THEIR
FAMILIES WILL HAVE ON THE LOCAL
ECONOMY. FROM A PURELY ECONOMIC
POINT OF VIEW THE DISABLED
VETERAN WILL BE IN A BETTER
POSITION TO PER SEARCH PURCHASE
MUCH NEEDED GOODS AND SERVICES
THUS CREATING ADDITIONAL TAX
REVENUE STREAMS. BACK TO THE
STATE COUNTIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES.
THE TAX REVENUE LOSS RUBIO HE
SAYS WOULD BE REALIZED IN ALL
ACTUALITY WOULD BE A FRACTION OF
WHAT TO BE ALWAYS ESTIMATED.
NINE ONE NINETY ONE POINT ONE
MILLION IS PROJECTED TO BE IT'S
JUST A DIFFERENT COLOR OF MONEY
COMING BACK AS TAXES GENERATED
THROUGH OTHER REVENUE SOURCES.
THEREFORE WE QUESTION.
IS IT REALLY A TAX DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR REVENUE LOSS OR SOME
FRACTION THEREOF.
AS THE OFFER OF AB THIRTY TWO OR
NINE SILLY JIM FRAZIER PUT IT.
AB THIRTY CHAU NINE WOULD HELP
ENSURE OUR DISABLED VETERANS
REMAINING CALIFORNIA IN THAT
OPTION OF LIVING NEAR MEDICAL
AND BASS FACILITIES AS WELL AS
CEMETERIES. PLACES A FINAL
TERMINATE BALANCED AGAINST THE
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL PROPOSED INCREASE
TWO THE STATE'S EXISTING
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION WILL HELP
ARE VETERANS OF FAMILIES REMAIN
IN OUR GOLDEN STATE.
IF TAXES
FLORIDA IN ILLINOIS IS JUST NAME
A FEW STATES THAT ARE FORWARD
LOOKING AND CAN HONOR THEIR
STATE'S. MOST SEVERELY INJURED
AN ILL VETERANS PROVIDING THEIR
HUNDRED PERCENT DISABLED
VETERANS FOR PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION.
SURELY THE FOURTH THE FOURTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD TO
FIND A WAY TO PROVIDE IT'S A
HUNDRED PERCENT SERVICE
CONNECTED DISABLED VETERANS THE
SAME HONOR.
IN CLOSING DELEGATES AT OUR MOST
RECENT DAB STATE CONVENTION
APPROVED RESOLUTION NUMBER NINE.
SEEK LEGISLATION THAT PROVIDES
ELIGIBLE DISABLED VETERANS A FOR
PROFIT TAX EXEMPTION. AMONG
OTHER PRIORITIES THIS RESOLUTION
CALLS ON THE STATE LEGISLATOR TO
LET THE CONSTITUTION
AUTHORIZATION BY PROVIDING
EXEMPTION OF THE FULL VALUE OF A
TOY DISABLED VETERANS RESIDENTS.
AND EXTENDS THE FULL VALUE TAX
EXEMPTION TO THE VETERANS ON
MERITS RIGHT SPOUSE.
OUR DELEGATES ALSO APPROVE
RESOLUTION NUMBER EIGHT.
SEEK LEGISLATION TO EXCLUDE
VETERANS DISABILITY COMPENSATION
FROM COUNTABLE INCOME FOR
PURPOSES OF ELIGIBILITY TO
BENEFITS. AND SERVICES UNDER
OTHER GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS MADAM
CHAIR THIS CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
WERE THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
OTHER TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
EXCEPT THREE BRIEF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
GI FORM OF CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
LEGION DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL. MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL CHAPTERS
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL ON
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
HE DEATH NEW MADAM CHAIR GEORGE
OSBORNE A MARINE CORPS VETERAN
OF THE VIETNAM WAR.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
ANY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COME.
COMMON.
I LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT HERE ON
THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
WELL DONE.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO.
ILLUSTRATE. THE DISABILITY
BENEFITS DEATH VETERANS GET.
JUST FOR A MOMENT AND BY THE WAY
FOR MY VETERAN FRIENDS OUT IN
THE PEANUT GALLERY.
BRAND NEW THIS IS A BRAND NEW
VETERANS BENEFIT BOOK.
GO UP TO FOUR ZERO ZERO NINE MY
OFFICE AND GRABBED BUNCH OF
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF.
IN HAND AMONG.
SO. A VETERAN.
HAS TEN PERCENT DISABILITY.
THAT GETS THEM ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX DOLLARS AND TWENTY
FOUR CENTS A MONTH.
TAX FREE.
IF A VETERAN HAS SEVENTY PERCENT
DISABILITY.
NOW WE'RE GETTING THERE.
ONE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS AND FORTY
EIGHT CENTS A MONTH.
NOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER.
IS SPOT ON HERE.
GOD BLESS YOUR.
IF A VETERAN IS A HUNDRED
PERCENT DISABLED.
AND MANY OF THOSE VETERANS
THEY'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING ELSE.
EVER AGAIN THEY CAN'T EVEN BE A
WALMART GREETER GREAT RESPECT TO
WALMART.
SO HUNDRED PERCENT DISABLED. TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE DOLLARS AND EIGHTY
SIX CENTS AND THAT VETERAN.
IS ON THAT PAY SCALE.
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIFE.
AND CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG
BECAUSE DEVON MATHIS KNOWS THIS
SYSTEM BETTER NOW I DO. THAT'S
OFFICER AND ENLISTED.
I BELIEVE SO.
.
SO THIS IS HUGE THIS IS
IMPORTANT AND IT ONLY COSTS
CALIFORNIA NINETY ONE. MILLION A
YEAR.
.
I.
I STRONGLY URGE EVERYONE TO VOTE
FOR THIS THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS MOVEMENT MISTER VOEPEL
YOU
YOUR CORRECT SIR.
.
THERE THERE'S ALSO KNOW COAL OF
THAT GOES WITH THAT HER ONGOING.
CREASES INFLATION GOES UP ARM.
BEING THAT I WAS TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD WHEN I WAS TOLD I WAS
HUNDRED PERCENT DISABLED AND. GO
HOME AND CHU ON A BAG OF PILLS.
NAM THINK THEY'RE DECIDING GO TO
COLLEGE INSTEAD NOW WE'RE HERE.
MAKING SURE OTHER VETERANS GET
THIS OPPORTUNITY MR FRAZIER THIS
IS A GODSEND. TO MANY VETERANS
WHO. WERE NOT ABLE TO GET THE
THERAPY THAT I WAS ABLE TO GET
IT IN OUR HOME AND STUCK IN A
RUT.
PRODUCED GETTING THROUGH ON THE
STRUGGLE IS REAL. AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HELPS.
OUR VETERANS IN.
IT'S.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S EXTREMELY
NEEDED.
BECAUSE AND I KNOW THE REAL
FIGHT IS GOING TO BE IN
APPROPRIATIONS.
TRYING TO GET THEM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO TAKE
MONEY AWAY FROM THE STATE WE'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO KEEP VETERANS
HERE AND PROTECT FUNDING. THAT.
.
TRUST ME PLAN IT WAS.
HOW THE A LOT OF VETERANS ARE
LEAVING THE STATE FOR MANY
REASONS?
ON THIS IS ONE STEP TO KEEP THEM
HERE.
AND.
IF I'M NOT ALREADY A CO AUTHOR
I WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED TODAY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER VOEPEL WAS INTERESTED IN
BEING A CO AUTHOR.
ALRIGHT.
ALRIGHT SO OF WE HAVE A MOTION
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS AND A
SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
MANAGER. I I JUST WANNA AS A
PROUD MEMBER OF THIS OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE VETERANS
COMMITTEE.
AND HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY AND
I WANT TO TELL YOU I AM SURE THE
GENTLEMAN SITTING TO MY RIGHT IS
THE ONE THAT SUGGESTED THIS BILL
LAST YEAR.
AND. I THOUGHT ABOUT AND THOUGHT
ABOUT AND THOUGHT ABOUT AND SAID
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE HONOR THESE
VETERANS IN A WAY THAT IS.
IS APPROPRIATE AND THIS IS A
STEP THAT WE ALL SHOULD BE
TAKING. OF FOR THEIR THEIR
SERVICE AND THERE ALSO THEIR
COMMITMENT TO OUR SAFETY AND AND
I THINK IT'S FROM THE BOTTOM MY
HEART'S A DEMOCRATIC TO THAT WE
JUST CAN'T REPAY BUT THIS STARTS.
SUCH A LITTLE BIT OF PAY BACK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS ON AB THIRTY
TWO PHONE NINE ME PLEASE WHO
WILL CALL.
IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE VOEPEL AYE
VOEPEL AYE CHáVEZ.
DALY. DALY AYE FRAZIER AYE
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I MATHIS. MATHIS AYE A
MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE.
EIGHT ZERO CONGRATULATIONS THAT
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS.
NDEB DONE IT THROUGH APPROPRIATE.
YEAH.
ALRIGHT.
.
WE WILL GO THROUGH THE I THINK
EVERYBODY'S VOTED ALREADY THAT.
MISTER FRAZIER.
YOU HAVE NOT VOTED ON CONSENT
YET. I.
ON CONSENT FRAZIER AYE.
ALRIGHT I WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPENED FOR.
SIX MINUTES.
SCHOOL FUNDING GARLIC THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED